and I think we should look to countries
like Denmark like Sweden and Norway but
we are not Denmark I love Denmark we're
the United States of America
what we need to do is create millions of
jobs by rebuilding our crumbling
infrastructure raise the minimum wage to
$15 an hour and make every public
college and university in this country
to wish it free sees heat or what
enlightens there would be the contrast
between Sweden and P American school
system because he will get paid to go to
school you do not Congress does not
regulate Wall Street Wall Street
regulates Congress I mean in Sweden you
can't even I don't think you can even go
from being like a business owner go from
there to a political candidate no I
don't think you can do that is Bernie
Sanders tough enough on guns no not at
all I think that we have to look at the
fact that we lose 90 people a day from
gun violence it's really odd for us to
hear about grown-ups really arguing
about where the guns should be allowed
or not I mean here in Sweden we have
pretty low murder rate or killing rate
and it's for a reason that we don't
allow guns in the public or in their
homes
millions of Americans are working longer
hours for lower wages and yet almost all
of the new income and wealth being
created is going to the top one percent
I felt like why is this even a
discussion because it's basically
slavery you get paid nothing to make
your life go around
definitely Bernie Sanders he's almost
like a Swede before I washed it the
debate I was instead I wasn't really
sure but now I really feel like Sanders
is a good candidate
I would definitely vote for Bernie
Sanders and I feel that he makes my
heart skip a beat
no word strikes more fear into the heart
of fox news anchors known forces